[Music]
we have to talk about this just
wall-to-wall coverage yeah the big story
hurricane sandy
is uh hitting the coast of new jersey
just i think as we speak right now it's
approaching new jersey here's the latest
new jersey governor chris christie's
message
to new jersey residents about hurricane
sandy was don't be stupid get out
that's what he said don't be stupid get
out
which by the way is also snooki's method
of birth control
it's true
yeah
[Applause]
this woman right here gasped in horror
at that one
he went
oh yeah well it would work
it gets rougher so hang on
the hurricane has interrupted the
presidential campaign
interrupted it yeah both presidential
candidates are taking measures to
prepare for hurricane sandy for example
president obama is staying in washington
to coordinate relief efforts and mitt
romney's moving his smaller homes into
his larger homes
he's taking them he's putting them in
[Applause]
you're safe right
that makes sense that's a good approach
sure you got to put the little houses
inside the big houses
thanks pal sure
i doubted myself
well of course all the important uh
authorities are involved in this crisis
lindsay lohan
lindsay lohan sent out a tweet urging
people not to panic over hurricane sandy
that's true she sent out a tweet yeah
lindsay said the correct time to panic
is if anyone sees me in a rental car
then you should evacuate the area
she probably peter probably read that
tweet and stopped putting up plywood
oh lindsay lohan says it's fine who
cares we better huh lindsay sulk okay no
problem
despite the hurricane there is a
presidential race going on it's heading
into the final stretch thank god
president obama this is the latest
president obama now has a 52-point lead
with hispanics
yeah
however
however mitt romney has a 90 point lead
with the people who hire hispanics
disparity
yeah
i accept your judgment yeah
i couldn't believe this this is uh
taking it to an extreme but a man in
indiana this is true a man in indiana
got a tattoo of mitt romney's campaign
logo on his face
yeah
friends describe the man as a staunch
republican who's never heard of bumper
stickers
technology technology playing a very big
part in this election it's been reported
that presidential campaigns are now
trying to reach voters based on their
web history
yeah
so this january get ready for the
inauguration of president porn
i see this crowd supports president porn
we've got a lot of supporters here for
president porn i can't wait till he
meets with ahmadinejad
he'll settle everything oh yeah
he'll bring this country together
yeah uh
[Music]
i don't even know what that meant
it just seemed unwise and you're like oh
and you again with the noises
celebrities though out stumping for
their candidates last week katy perry
katy perry spoke at a pro-obama rally in
a skin-tight dress
yeah
people who were there said perry had two
good points
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was quite good
right like that this man
wasn't for breasts yes
[Laughter]
crazy science story got to share this
with you a study has found that the air
in rome
contains traces of cocaine
yeah so maybe rome was built in a day
[Music]
you